hello there today i'm talking to kevin
bock who is a cyber security expert and
one of the main people involved in the
geneva project geneva is a genetic
algorithm that evades censorship by
nation states so in real time geneva can
evolve to the ever more present danger
of censorship by really big entities
such as governments all of this is done
through an evolutionary search over a
program grammar and in this interview
we're going to touch on a whole range of
topics including geneva how it works
what it does why people research it and
what it has done so far in the world but
also the broader topics of security and
its connections to ai how people can get
started in this field and what the main
questions and problems are in this space
further geneva comes out of a project at
the university of maryland called
breaker space which is a sort of lab
that includes undergraduates in security
research which is a really cool project
and i think highlighting this would be
helpful to some people maybe you're at
the university you don't know this
exists go there take part all right
without further ado i want to give over
to the interview and have fun
[Music]
all right everyone i have with me today
here kevin bach who is a phd student at
the university of maryland a cyber
security researcher and a member of
breaker space which is a pretty cool
project at the university of maryland he
also has been in the news a little bit
with a project that's called geneva
which uses genetic algorithms to evade
censorship by nation states and i think
that's pretty cool so kevin welcome to
the show and uh thanks for being here
thank you thank you for having me i'm
excited to be here so the goal of today
it's a little bit different because i'm
a total noob at security most of the
audience of this channel is not
is into machine learning maybe some know
about security some know about um
the the censorship apparatus that's in
place around the world and what people
do about it i think most won't so today
i'll be asking mostly noob-ish questions
and um we'll have you here to guide us
through everything to guide us through
like what's happening in this world so
maybe you first can start off a little
bit how did you get into like how did
you get to the place where you are
what's kind of the the main things in
security right now that draw you to it
so i think security and the censorship
space also is in this this really cool
um this really cool time where
ai and ml techniques have been exploding
in all these other fields and they're
just over the last four years really
breaking into security and we're still
figuring out all the different
applications where you can apply these
techniques in security there's new
techniques and new applications of this
that people are discovering all the time
from better ways to detect spam and
better ways to identify hey this domain
is malicious or
ai-based scanners for that that binary
you downloaded that's probably malware
things like that so security field is
still discovering all sorts of new ways
you can apply these techniques
and that was one of my motivations
initially actually of bringing this
censorship because this project was
really the entire field of censorship's
first foray into using ai and ml like
techniques
and if you if you talk about censorship
what do you mean exactly by that
yes there's a
so many forms of censorship in in
in effect around the world today i mean
everything from political pressure to
self-censorship to taking down po like
there's so many different types so i'm
going to scope this discussion down a
little bit just the type of censorship
that we study in this lab
and that's this type of
automated censorship that happens in the
network performed by nation states so
what do i mean by this um if you're a
user in certain regimes around the world
let's say in iran or something and you
try and make a request as that request
as that web traffic crosses through the
the border to the country
it is
scanned parsed and inspected by some
machines that physically reside in the
network called middle boxes called
because they're in the middle of the
network and these middle boxes examine
your requests and they say is this
something we should allow or not and if
the answer's no they either inject
traffic to take down your connection or
they drop your connection or they do
something to disrupt what's going on and
you'll notice everything i just said
there there's no human in the loop
there's there's no like human content
review or anything like this it's it's a
purely automated run by these middle
boxes or firewalls deployed by these
nations that just like automatically
inspect internet traffic as they go by
so that's really the scope of what we've
been studying here naive question
why why can't i just encrypt my traffic
and then like every traffic looks the
same towards the outside
yeah that's a great question so why
can't we just encrypt everything
people have been trying
so there's like a couple different
approaches to this you're like well
let's just use https right encrypted
we're good
unfortunately https has a small privacy
leakage
when you first set up an https
connection and that very first initials
called a handshake got first back and
forth
you as the client as a part of the
protocol you have to announce the domain
you're talking to and that announcement
happens unencrypted so if you're making
a https handshake to wikipedia
in the very first packet you send it's
going to include the word wikipedia
and that's called the server name
indication field you indicate to the
server what the name of the server
you're trying to talk to
and unfortunately sensors just read that
fields and then they take down your
connection if you're talking to a
forbidden domain so https unfortunately
not close but not quite finishing the
job now i will say there there have been
just a quick sidebar there have been
some advancements in hbs to try and fix
this um there's a recent proposal to
encrypt that field uh it's called
encrypted sni um and china just started
centering censoring that last year
so the
you can try and encrypt things but these
sensors are often just hostile to um the
idea of just letting their letting their
citizens just encrypt all their traffic
i guess it's it's a little bit like if
everyone encrypts like with https
nowadays everyone does it so you can't
conceivably block https you know just
just because you don't like some traffic
but if there's a new type of encryption
uh you you can probably it's probably
only the people that have something to
hide that use that type of encryption so
is is like is a strategy that the rest
of the world as fast as possible would
use these techniques to kind of make
that approach unusable
that's exactly that's exactly right the
the broader topic you're actually
discovering and saying out loud here is
this idea of collateral damage
of can we make a protocol or something
so popular and used so diversely that if
a sensor were to try and block it it
would cause irreparable harm to like
good services there's some meaningful
cost to performing that censorship so
just like you've identified https that's
everywhere they can't just shut down all
https but rolling out a new encryption
method for https that's not very widely
deployed they can nip that in the bud
and prevent its rollout so there's this
kind of this interesting a race in a
game between developers and these
sensors that's still being played out
now let's let's
talk about more let's say
naive approaches what is the
the development of the field like what
has been tried before and what has been
let's say thwarted or what's the cat and
mouse game looked like in the past i
imagine different things like there's
tor there is you know all kinds of
things there is probably things that
everyone installs on their end like vpns
and tunnels and so on like what's what's
been the general development
over the years
yeah so the
researchers and sensors have been
playing this cat mass game for two
decades now and it's kind of evolved and
it's been playing out in multiple fronts
um so you're exactly right tor has been
a huge uh front on that war if you will
like we've developed tour and continued
to advance it
unfortunately though there are some
limitations just the tor protocol and
sensors can enumerate
the tour entry points basically and just
block you so once you get into tour
you're generally great but they try and
lock you out
um there's been all sorts of techniques
people from people have proposed like
maybe i can disguise my traffic to look
like skype and then the sensor is like
well you didn't disguise it quite well
enough blocked um
there's a whole interesting field of
defeating censorship or some field i
should say um called packet packet
manipulation based censorship and this
is this idea where
um all our communication is happening
via packets and if you just tweak those
packets in just the right way uh you
could cause the sensor to miss you
um and historically that's also been
something that's played out in this cat
and mouse game where researchers were
will study these sensor systems and then
they'll find a loophole and they'll
deploy and use it and then the sensor is
like oh i'll fix that and then we're
back to square zero so this this game
has really been continuing to play um
i'll call one thing out real quickly
about vpns because a lot of people
particularly those who have been to
china are like i've been able to use a
vpn but it's been okay um
vpns in in many places work in many
places they don't there's a country in
the news recently um
they were in the news because they
rolled out a new law that forced their
citizens to swear on the quran that they
would not use a vpn in order to get
internet access installed in their homes
it's just like a crazy sentence to say
out loud yeah
but in china for example these vpns they
many of them work most of the time
but what researchers have noticed is
that around the time politically
sensitive events are happening or
political uh
such as elections things like this a lot
of vpns will just mysteriously stop
working yeah and then after the event
they'll mysteriously start working again
and it kind of points to this broader
idea that some of these countries may be
sitting on more censorship capability
than they deploy on a daily basis um and
they they have more power than they use
um so this cat and mouse game may even
be like the cat may even be stronger
than we think it is yeah
uh this this this can you give us an
idea of what this packet manipulation uh
evasions look like because i imagine
something you mentioned before you know
if there's wikipedia in the hater i
don't want my population to see
wikipedia like that's it right what can
i possibly manipulate there in order to
get it to get through such censorship
yeah so we can think about sensors um as
our computers are sending packets around
you can imagine a lot of that
communication like you're writing mail
and your packets are envelopes that are
going that are going through the network
and in order to have a communication
with a server like wikipedia that's
going to take a couple a couple
envelopes back and forth right and the
sensor is just like the postman in the
middle reading all your letters
unfortunately that postband's got to
process a lot of letters a lot of
letters and you can imagine the
something that scale of like china
you're you're dealing with a huge huge
volume of traffic just at a constant
basis
what that means is the sensor can't just
remember everything it sees
okay so for example if it's trying to if
it's trying to track that hey that
person over there is trying to talk to
that server over there and that person
over there is talking that server over
there that state it has to maintain
right the this amount of state it has to
maintain it'll grow and it's in the size
of some word like china it could grow
pretty fast
so they have to be really careful about
what they remember in the state they
maintain so you can imagine doing
something like let's let's say we're
exchanging packets there's exists a type
of packet called the reset packet and
these are normal packets our computers
send these all the time but they
basically just exist to tell the other
side stop talking to me immediately i'm
hanging up the connection
so you can imagine doing something like
you and i are communicating we're
sending these packets back and forth and
i just slip one additional packet into
the connection towards the beginning and
it's reset packet
and i'll send that packet along and when
the postman sees that packet he's like
well these guys have stopped
communicating after this message he's
going to ignore him forever and then he
throws away the state he's maintaining
about our connection he forgets that
we're talking because why would he need
to remember anymore he thinks we're done
and if i craft that pack in such a way
that it won't make it to you or you'll
see it and ignore it or something like
this then we'll be able to still
communicate fine right like our our
communication is unimpacted but any
other packets that go by the sensor is
like i don't know who this is yeah
and you can get through so this is like
the broad strokes this idea of packet
manipulation based censorship where
you're you're tweaking the packets that
go by to try and
basically trick the sensor that's in the
middle into letting you continue to talk
now do i do i see this correctly that
there have been like a giant amount of
these schemes proposed and as you say
there's a cat and mouse game one is
being proposed then they fix it then
another one then they fix it so that
points to
the possibility of what if we could have
something dynamic right what if we could
have something that by itself tries to
invent new things and that's where you
went with geneva do i understand that
correctly that's exactly correct yeah
you're spot on
yeah so over the years there's been
i want to say dozens of these that have
been proposed and researchers have it's
exactly what is exactly this cat masking
they studied the censorship system i
mean the sensory system's not public so
they're probing it they're they're
trying to take measurements that's a lot
of work and then they get an
understanding they apply their good
human intuition they develop something
cool and publish it and the sensor fixes
it and they don't tell you they fixed it
yeah they don't they don't publish a
paper that's like hey we just fixed your
bug
so it just resets the score zero and so
the idea with with geneva which stands
for genetic invasion
the idea of this was
it's an algorithm that could kind of
flip this process on its head so instead
of a human having to to take the
approach of let's understand how the
censorship works and then defeat it
let's just have some ai or fuzzer or
automated system
just attack the sensor figure out ways
through and then give it to the human
and now after the fact my slow human
brain can go figure out why that thing
worked and now my brain is no longer the
bottleneck to helping people get through
the sensor
how does how does this you want to go a
bit more into detail i mean it sounds
great at the surface but there's a
reason right we need security
researchers probing making sense and
there's a reason that's the bottleneck
if i were just to be like well you know
fuzz a bit um it's probably not gonna
work so
what what does what does geneva do
uh that allows it to even be successful
where maybe humans
take a long time or wouldn't be
successful
yes there were a couple pretty
significant challenges when we first
started in applying something like a
genetic algorithm or really any ai to
the space of censorship and if you think
about the way censorship works it's not
hard to imagine like why that's the case
because if you think about
think about a censorship problem right
like a query is either censored or it's
not it's just a binary decision
so it's not like your traditional ml or
ai where you have this nice like
gradient descent there's no error you
get back from the sensor the sensor
doesn't tell you like hey if you tweet
your query just a little bit you're
getting closer yeah you know there's no
gradient which with which you could work
so that that property alone rules out
the majority of the ml field as far as
approaches you can take is there even a
loss like you said it's hard to detect
if you even get through how do you do
that in the first place how do you
notice success or failure
yeah so in our case you're exactly right
dude
capturing that could be difficult um
what we do to make it easier in
ourselves is we obtain machines inside
these censored countries and directly
try to request for written context so
geneva trains directly against the
sensor and we know we got it because
when the sensor takes action is kind of
obvious
so geneva will try and obtain some
forbidden content while manipulating a
packet stream and then if it succeeds
great if it fails
we'll know yeah
right so this idea of how do we apply ml
ai
some fuzzing to this space like what how
do we how do we build this
um there's a couple main challenges
towards doing that the first is this
total lack of gradient that i mentioned
um and really that only leaves you with
kind of a small number of approaches um
and we chose to go down the route of
let's use a genetic algorithm for this
there's some nice properties it's it's
easily explainable you can understand
how it works while it runs
it's a little less black boxy than
something more like a neural net or
something or markov or something like
this
so but if you want to build a genetic
algorithm you need a couple of things
um you're seeing what some of these
strategies look like right here
um so if you want to build a genetic art
there's a couple things you need you
need some some building blocks something
that
something that the algorithm can compose
and put together um and you need some
way for it to put those things together
i mean us humans as examples as far as
like genetics goes we've got our dna
bases right actg
and our we can put those together in dna
for the genetic algorithm for geneva we
needed to decide what what makes sense
for
building blocks for the algorithm to use
um and that alone is like an initial
really huge challenge because you could
be creative and then you can think about
a million different ways
an algorithm could manipulate a packet
right flip a bit you could flip this bit
like there's just so many different
things you could
give it to do
so one of the first challenges we had to
figure out was how do we balance what
this algorithm can and cannot do
to the data it has and on one hand we
could let it flip any bit um the
downside of that is it could take like
forever to learn to check some but it's
super powerful
like on the other other extreme there we
could
just encode what previous researchers
found and let it like play with those
together it would be super fast but it'd
be hard to learn anything new right we'd
just be building in biases directly
so the approach we ended up taking was
giving geneva basically the same ability
to change traffic as what the network
itself could do
so the network itself has just a few set
primitives they can do the packets you
can take a packet make multiple packets
you can duplicate them it can change a
header to something it's tampering a
packet you can take a packet break in
multiple pieces fragmenting you can take
it back and drop it which is just
basically deleting the package
um so we build out these building blocks
and then allow it to compose these
things together in trees yeah so like
syntax like you give it a syntax and it
can perform
it can assemble a little program out of
this syntax one like one we see right
here
that's exactly correct can you walk us
through what this particular thing does
sure sure this is
uh this is a
this is this is kind of a fun this is
kind of a fun strategy um so there's a
few different components to a geneva
strategy i'll break down the syntax for
you real fast what these programs look
like
so the first component is the idea of a
trigger the trigger is what's between
the the square brackets so there's two
triggers in this tcp flags s and tcp
flags are
and when geneva is monitoring traffic
the trigger tells it which packet should
i act upon
so this first trigger you see here it
says tcp flags s
okay so that means that whatever actions
are attached to that trigger will run on
any syn packet it sees s stands for sin
and sin means the start of my connection
so what this is going to do to that
packet is the very first action we see
is duplicate so that means it's going to
take that packet and make two of them
now duplicate
the syntax of this is it's one set of
actions comma another set of actions so
you'll see the two actions you see here
are tamper and then send
so the second duplicate we do nothing to
so the second syn pad the second
duplicate we're just going to send on
the wire
but to the first duplicate what we're
going to do is we're going to replace
the flags fields in that packet with
synac sa
and then we're going to send that packet
so basically what this little program
does is it sees outgoing synap packets
outgoing syn packets to your computer
and it duplicates them to make two
packets and then replaces the flags in
the first one with cynic
now any networking person listening is
like this is clearly ridiculous this
this never should work like why why
would why would we even do this why are
we talking about this and what's going
on here is that for certain sensors
around the world uh synack is the packet
that's typically sent by a server it's
never sent by a client
so what's going on in this in this
strategy is when the client sends a
synack the sensor says whoa i must admit
something this client is clearly a
server which means the server must be
the client yeah it reverses the roles of
client server in the mind of the sensor
and as a consequence when the client
makes the real request since the sensor
is processing packets differently
between client surfer you're through i
see so that's this idea of the strategy
so that connection in the in the mind of
the sensor is already established as
here's a server here as a client and it
kind of keeps that state for subsequent
packages
more or less yep that's exactly it yeah
so let's this is an example of just one
strategy and one of these programs that
so geneva built this program itself and
it built this through the process of
evolution yeah and you've discovered
just to to to jump ahead a little bit
because we're not through yet with
explaining exactly how it works but
you've discovered that geneva will
actually reproduce a lot of the uh a lot
of the
common or known or or already discovered
uh
discovered things that researchers have
proposed right yeah we had this with
this really cool result initially where
we set out to try and uh we wanted to we
first developed this tool kind of bench
market against the the rest of the
fields um and that that's kind of
challenging because sensors have
continued to evolve yeah so we did was
we sat down in the lab and we
implemented in the lab
our best guess as to what our our best
implementation i should say as to what
these sensors look like based on what
previous researchers found and then
trained geneva against these mock
sensors and also trained it against the
great firewall and and real sensors
where we could
um and we found was very quickly it was
able to reproduce basically the entire
field yeah um every strategy human had
come up with this this also found and it
found pretty quickly um so it's really
showing the power of automated
approaches and ai and ml yeah
so you have you have uh let's let's get
back a little bit you have this syntax
right that you can build uh trees from
which are valid programs in geneva this
will modify the traffic somehow now to
say that most of this traffic will just
not even be traffic probably like it
will like the connection will be somehow
bad uh some of it will go through and
some of it will actually maybe evade the
sensor what do we need to get there what
do we need to um
you know to to get to a place where
i guess if you just do it naively and
you randomize a little bit it will just
be bad like 99.9
of all the programs you generate you'll
initiate them and then after a while
you'll see like my traffic doesn't even
isn't isn't even getting anywhere right
so what are the like of the genetic
algorithm components what do we still
need
yeah so we're we're building our way up
to the united we've got just like you
said we got our building blocks we got a
way to put them together we got a syntax
that we can build these programs out of
and we can run these programs on network
traffic and you're exactly correct that
if we initialize completely randomly
it's going to do terribly and that's
exactly what happens we've tested this
um so what what where do we need to go
from here now that we have this
so this this kind of brings us to this
idea of let's let's let's get evolution
in the mix
so you can imagine
you can imagine the way the way this
works is we have a big pool of
strategies okay we'll call this a
population
and each of these populations just take
for granted for now that we have some
diverse set of strategies in here
and we have a way to test them right we
can try and make a request for something
forbidden and we can run these programs
on those requests as we make them so for
example from inside of china we can try
and access wikipedia that's a sense of
resource and we'll have these programs
running on that connection we'll just
try and make that connection over and
over again
what we'll see is some of these
strategies will destroy our connection
some of them will just not work at all
and do terribly some of them might let
her some of them might keep our
connection alive and maybe if we get
crazy lucky we'll defeat censorship but
for now let's just say a whole bunch of
them will just destroy our connection
and maybe somewhat
what we have is a fitness function and
this fitness function uh this is it just
borrow some a much broader space in ml
and ai but it's basically this idea of
if you take in
some individual from the population
some individual strategy how good is
this thing
survival the fittest like should this
thing survive basically continue to
propagate its genetic material
so this was actually the second big
challenge in applying ai and ml to the
space of sensitive division of what on
earth should a fitness function look
like in this space because just like we
talked about earlier there's no gradient
right and even even coming with like a
loss function can be a little tricky and
i mean even if if like
sorry to interrupt but if the fitness
even like if if the i guess the fitness
is it anything else than zero like okay
maybe some connections don't even work
to like the server next to you you can
discard those but other than that the
fitness is either doesn't reach the
target or does reach the target and if
it does you've kind of won right like
how can you even get a meaningful signal
is there a fitness in between zero and
one
yeah so and and part of what makes
geneva work is we've kind of shoehorned
our way into getting fitness between
zero and one um and specifically what we
do is
is
rule out those strategies that break
your own connection um so that that's
kind of how we've gotten between zero
and one cause it's not it's not
technically zero or one it's almost
negative one zero one and negative one
is geneva's shooting itself in the foot
right it's just like dropping all your
traffic like that's never gonna work and
we shouldn't even bother exploring that
space more right like we're never going
to go anywhere
but if you can make it so that your
packets are at least interacting with
the sensor and at least have the
potential into the server well now we
might be getting somewhere
so basically what we do is we set up the
fitness function in such a way that if
strategies destroy the underlying
connection they'll be punished severely
and basically killed off
and strategies that interact with the
sensor even though they get sensors
they'll get a slightly higher fitness
function than those other ones
so what's going to happen is because
those those individuals aren't they're
not successful but they're still the
most successful in the population pool
which means some subset of them will
continue to reproduce basically that
subset's just chosen randomly
but because we're just choosing randomly
mutation is still going to happen so
we're basically taking a set of
individuals they all interact with the
sensor and then we just mutate them and
try again and then mutate them and try
again and effectively what this is
turned into is a fuzzer like geneva is
the the fitness function is basically
makes this a targeted fuzzer where we
can fuzz just the space of strategies
just the space of programs that allow us
to interact with the sensor
and then where it gets interesting is as
this fuzzer is running generation after
generation just trying different crazy
things against the sensor if it finds
something that gets through suddenly
that fitness is way higher than
everything else
and that individual will start sharing
its genetic material and propagating
within the population pool
at that point we could stop we could
stop the fitness function right there
but we optionally add some additional
punishments and rewards for the
algorithm at this point
and specifically we add
basically a punishment for strategy
complexity so if if this if an
individual is successful we optionally
punish it for
basically the number of actions and the
amount of overhead it adds to connection
and the reason we do that is this is not
strictly required but i have a very
small smooth human brain and it's so
much easier to understand a strategy
that's only two actions long compared to
something that's 50 actions for example
so if we could encourage the algorithm
like great you've got a solution now
simplify it down for me and it will over
the course of generations whittle it
down to its smallest form and then at
the end presents you its population pool
and its its best individuals
um and and we we see here a few ways you
can mutate i think this this just
essentially comes down to changing the
syntax syntax tree in some form um yep
and these are basically you can yeah you
can imagine all the different ways you
could you could take these programs and
mix them around if you can think about
it geneva could probably do it yeah
and so just
um maybe for for my understanding but
you're trying all of this you you say
you have some machines inside of these
countries aren't and i read some like
obviously this is not going to work
against ip blocking like how do you how
do you not get ip blocked by them if
like i imagine there's like some weird
traffic that's you know
hits my censorship wall all the time um
why don't i just be like well gone
yeah that's a good question and we get
this question a lot actually
and you're kind of pointing to this this
broader question of like what's the
sensor's response yeah you're doing all
these wacky crazy ridiculous things i
mean there's a strategy in there that
just lights up every tcp flag like that
package shouldn't exist flatly it did it
has no meaning on the network but geneva
tried it found it and found that it
works um so where do you sensor where do
sensors go from here um it sounds like
we're talking about things like it's
sending crazy packets it sounds like
that should be something that's easy to
detect on the network
um but it sounds easy until you try and
write it um because if you think about
it writing something to detect
abnormality when you have no idea what
that abnormality looks like
um especially in the space of just like
just how random and crazy the internet
is all the time
um identifying that is actually harder
than it sounds
and what makes it potentially even
harder is that a lot of the middle boxes
that would be doing that detecting is
exactly the middle boxes geneva's
mucking with with these strategies so it
may be the case that their detectors are
also getting screwed up whatever an
imaginary detector would also be getting
screwed up by these same strategies yeah
so
it's something they could take an action
against but we haven't seen any sensors
roll out something like this
something else you could imagine the
existing fitness functions just
described for geneva it kind of assumes
a static adversary like an adversary
that's not playing along if you will i
mean it's also assuming an adversary
that's not doing anything special to
hunt it out
and you could imagine a sensor that's a
little more sophisticated than that so
something we've kept an eye on is is at
the end of the future if either the
sensor starts rolling out ai ml
techniques or if the sensor
starts hunting for traffic that looks
very abnormal
and you can imagine encoding additional
uh bits into the fitness function such
that you could encourage geneva to make
this strategy blend in with normal
traffic i want this look as normal as
possible but still get through things
like this so you could imagine all sorts
of modifications to the fitness function
to make
an algorithm like this a stronger
competitor against an adversary that's
also playing along
but we haven't seen the adversaries do
that yet so we haven't needed to i was
surprised when we talked to a bunch of
you know also people in in the
intersection of security and machine
learning that uh there are as you say
these ml based let's say malware
detectors or or things like this i guess
also weird traffic detectors and and
people use them for example for company
networks and so on and these are to my
surprise also for example vulnerable to
adversarial attacks so there's an entire
new direction opening which usually
people imagine adversarial attacks like
ah i changed the image a little bit and
it's really this distinction between how
the human sees it and how the machine
sees it but you know in malware it's
like just bits and i feel like you know
very small number of bits there's
nothing like how the human sees it and
how the machine sees it it's so weird um
but yeah i think
i think
it's it's pretty cool and you got some
attention in the media
and the the articles usually go
something like uh
this ai can evade censorship or
something like this
and um now knowing that you use genetic
algorithms uh what do you
how do you think
how was how's your work received in the
media what do you think about it do you
do you feel like they are kind of trying
to
put a few buzz words in there or were
you happy with it
in general pretty happy and i i've kind
of been lucky to i mean even just
discussions like this or we could talk
about the work in a deeper context than
just like throwing buzzwords around um
like this is just an awesome way to kind
of cut through that that buzzwordy um
uh fanfare if you will yeah um so i've
been kind of lucky and you always going
to see buzzwords attached to things
that's always something like that but um
yeah i'd say overall it's been it's been
received positively and things like this
really would help us get there cool and
the so just saying the code for geneva
is available it's on github um you know
anyone can anyone can i guess look it up
your builds fail right now i'll i just
have to tell you i'm sorry um
yeah we're switching between ci systems
and haven't finished the migration okay
i mean yes
uh nothing new here um
so where is is there i mean there is a
lot of open space here it seems the
genetic algorithms are very cool they're
they're like a a basis right here um do
you think there are more places where uh
like machine learning techniques
especially you said you know we kind of
have to draw back from the
gradient-based approaches but there are
definitely
there's definitely possibilities if you
think of something like you know alphago
or something like this that's it's a
discrete game but also you know they
they work with neural networks that for
example uh when you build your tree your
modifications that guide that somehow
that you know
have an idea which of the modifications
might lead to a better algorithm to a
worse algorithm and so on do you see any
sort of uh evolvement that could happen
there definitely definitely our when we
first wrote geneva our goal was not to
be
the last ai approached the space it was
to be the first and hopefully the worst
yeah it would be great if
viewers out there hey take a crack at
this
there's all sorts of new techniques out
there just waiting to be applied this
this space is
it's rich and it's interesting and it's
impactful like this is the kind of space
where you discover something and get
that out of the worlds you're helping
journalists and activists like right now
so
it we're really excited to see where
this where the space goes and continues
to blossom so yeah all sorts of all
sorts of techniques just waiting to be
applied and are you also actively
investigating the the sensors side
because i imagine that uh the more or
the more capable
you are in censoring things also the
better you can research counter
strategies
so a bit we've tried to tailor our
research in such a way that we're not
directly helping a sensor we never want
to publish a paper that's like really
the use case of this is just making
sensors better like so
if we do do research down that vein it's
purely in service of let's make evasion
better yeah um we and we've tried to be
very good about not releasing anything
and not not publishing anything that's
directly hey sensors
this new technique man that's going to
really change the game for you should
try and roll that out so uh
i guess that answers your question yeah
yeah um well if you if you look ahead
you say yeah we said that the space is
wide open what would be what do you see
as a a
like maybe a bit of a north star for for
the field like for let's say censorship
evasion or something like this what
would be
characteristics of an ideal algorithm
that's a really good question
an ideal algorithm something to shoot
for
um so i think i can answer that question
by talking to i guess how this
how the the problem of censorship is
getting harder um and getting more
complicated um so as censorship is
continuing to evolve like this this cat
and mass game exists
it's not just sensors patching bugs like
sensors themselves are flawlessly
getting more sophisticated they're
getting better
and one direction that we think
sensors will start exploring in the
future is this idea of more personalized
censorship so instead of censorship
policies being rolled out for their
entire country you could imagine a
system where users with
elevated social credit scores or
different professions things like this
could access different content online
and be subjected to different different
forms of censorship
and in cases like this something like
just directly applying geneva gets a
little bit harder because you can't just
apply geneva in one vantage point and
help everybody right like you need to
suddenly have a way to to reach more
people and help more people at once um
so
it's this question of how can we scale
this up in a large way and how can we
scale this up
safely in a way that protects itself
from attacks from the adversary like the
nations they can see our traffic so in
theory they could muck with the training
how can we prevent that
so in crafting this like ideal
algorithmic circumstances a lot of
things you have to consider
so i think building towards this idea of
can we do federated training across a
large a large population can we do this
in a way that protects users can we make
the algorithm more efficient so it needs
it needs less connections to figure
things out
all sorts of things like this i think
are
really good goals to shoot for and that
is more people viewers try this out as
more people like jump into the space and
play with this these are some of the
problems they're going to be building
towards is there any work on like
screwing with the sensors like i imagine
that if i you know if i build an evasion
attack that has like a really low
hanging fruit of fixing it and that fix
in itself would somehow be
you know completely
uh devastating but i don't know it when
i implement it um is there work in this
direction
so is there work in the space of mucking
with sensors definitely um crafting the
kind of attack you describe is kind of
tricky because we don't know what the
sensor's code looks like yeah you know
now there is this there is this idea of
there are there are bugs and and
limitations that as they patch them may
expose them to other attacks
so one quick example of this if you go
back to our analogy if we're sending
letters back and forth
um a common a common limitation that
many less sophisticated sensors
experience is they can't if i've taken a
packet or taken a letter and i break
into two letters
they can't put them back together yeah
right and that's that's like a huge
limitation because it's really easy for
me just to take it back and split it up
and send it through
so to fix that the sensor all it needs
to do all it needs to do is remember
every packet it sees and then stitch it
back together based on the numbers on
each of the packets
so that's like a simple fix to a
limitation but when you apply that fix
you open yourself up to the entire space
of attacks of maybe i can sneak a letter
in there that you think belongs halfway
through the message but it actually
belongs to the beginning or it actually
belongs to the end or it actually
doesn't belong in that at all
um and so you have this is one example
that we've seen in the wild where
this idea of
i have i need to fix the limitation and
by fiction limitation i've opened myself
up to a dozen other potential attacks so
that definitely exists how how um
how
i'm just thinking uh
from my noobish understanding right here
how much of a problem is it that our
protocols are rather fixed i imagine if
i could if i had like a dynamic language
where if i communicate with anyone the
first step would actually be to
negotiate a protocol in a very dynamic
way right that would sort of give me the
possibility much more to together with
the person that i want to communicate
with uh negotiate something that could
get around these sensors in a in a
completely adaptive fashion is that at
all feasible or is there some some flaw
so is it feasible maybe um i mean that
if if such a thing like that could be
built it'd be incredible yeah it'd be
awesome so ai people ai people watching
get on that because that sounds good
that sounds awesome
there are definitely some challenges
into rolling that out and
um you basically need to get in the
headspace of if i roll up this protocol
and the sensor knows about it what is it
going to do what is it going to do
so there are there are protocols that
exist out there where
from the very first byte you send the
whole thing is encrypted
and in that case it's pretty hard to
fingerprint right there's it never looks
the same it's always just a stream of
random looking bytes but the sensor can
also find that just by looking for
something that looks like a random
stream of bytes and just like you said
that protocol never changes it always
looks the same
so if you you need to really develop a
system that's flexible and dynamic
enough that today it looks like this
protocol tomorrow looks like this
protocol today it looks like nothing in
between so you really need to be very
creative and very deliberate with how
you do it
so i i'm not aware of anything like that
personally maybe someone's working on it
out there but it would be awesome if you
could do it now speaking of
mocking with sensors you also have other
work that
uses the censorship infrastructure so
essentially anything that's in place
from the sensors to perform some some
attacks as i understand it uh any any
attack you could do
is actually made
potentially worse by the censorship
infrastructure such as a ddos attack or
something like this do you want to talk
a little bit about that
i would love to yeah so an area of work
that we went that we started exploring a
year or two ago uh something we noticed
for a lot of these sensors is
um when you interact with them as a user
like they need to respond to you they
need to send you some traffic right like
if i'm if i'm trying to request some
resource
and that resource is forbidden maybe the
sensor sends me a block page and that
block page says hey you're not allowed
to access this
and the thing is that that communication
there what's going on is my request can
often be much smaller than the size of
the block page i get back
so as an attacker this opens up the
space of hey maybe i can use the sensor
to launch an attack at somebody else by
making a request for forbidden things
pretending to be someone else
and then letting them send that huge
response at that other person
um and this is a this is an idea of a
reflected attack or an amplification
attack because as an attacker i can make
a tiny request and get a bigger request
out of it so i'm amplifying my traffic
so amplification attacks
so we started exploring whether we could
do this
to sensors and you use these nation
state sensors or even just beyond
sensors there's normal firewalls like
things that universities or just regular
networks organizations have deployed
but we discovered hundreds and hundreds
tens of thousands millions of ip
addresses that were behind these sensors
that we could use to launch these
attacks yeah and found these attacks got
crazy powerful
and the
so the
the who does it hurt more the sensors or
the final recipients of this the attack
yeah so in this case
the the weight is beared by both but the
brunt of the impact will be felt by the
victim yeah so this line of work it
mucks with the sensor but really really
the some of the i want to say the
purpose or
something you could distill this work
down to was
sensors are causing more harm to the
internet then they're not just the harm
of a sensor is not just restricted to
the citizens within its borders like a
sensor anywhere is a threat to anyone
everywhere yeah um so it's it's this the
work was less about let's flood a
sensors network and more about let's
prove to the world these things are
dangerous when they've been applied as
carelessly as they've been deployed now
other than block pages you have some you
have some very specific schemes of what
you do specific to these censorship
infrastructures that make these attacks
even more powerful what what are
examples of that
yeah so discovering these attacks in the
first place i'm making it sound very
simple right you just send a request and
then the response gets through um but
i'm skipping over kind of an enormous
step in here because what i've just
described send a request pretending to
be someone else should not be possible
yeah that sentence should not exist and
it shouldn't be a thing you can do and
the reason that's the case is because
when we make requests all the time this
happens i think there's a i think
there's a gif in there that explains
exactly what i'm saying just scroll up a
little bit
there's a three-way handshake that we
need to complete um
and that three handshake is just this
short exchange of packets i think it's
the one right above that it's the short
exchange of packets at the very
beginning right here short exchange of
packets that exists at the very
beginning of our connection and as an
attacker if i try and spoof it through a
handshake if i pretend to be my victim
and start the handshake
the server's going to respond to the
victim and so i won't be able to get the
critical bit of information i need from
that handshake to finish it and i need
to finish that handshake in order to
make a request
so throughout all of the up all of
networking history basically up until
this paper it's been assumed that tcp
this underlying protocol behind all
these requests
is immune to these type of amplification
attacks largely immune there's a small
caveat there but it's not worth getting
into
so
how do we go about addressing this
problem
we used geneva and ai techniques
and basically we replaced geneva's
fitness function and we we told geneva
hey you can talk to these sensors but
instead of rewarding you for getting
forbidden content we're going to do is
we're going to reward you for getting
content without establishing a
connection and we're going to reward you
for getting the biggest content you
possibly can
so kind of turning the fuzzer on its
head a little bit and letting it explore
the space of strategies that a
confuses the middle box into responding
so tricky into thinking we have a
connection already yeah and then b once
we've tricked it getting the biggest
possible response we can and so this
this is a second set of work that was
really powered by the same geneva
genetic algorithm and we were able to
use the same set of the building blocks
and primitives and programs that we had
developed previously yeah we just
applied them in a new way
and this is if i understand it is not a
weakness in tcp like if tcp were
implemented correctly geneva wouldn't
be able or shouldn't be able to find
something around this but this is
specifically because these middle boxes
are in there right
yeah you're spot on um tcp tcp itself is
not the problem it's the implementation
of tcp yeah and that's partially why we
did this paper we did this work you
can't just study tcp itself you can't
like download the protocol specification
like think really hard yeah because
that's not going to help you you need to
actually study real world sensors
so that's what we did we took geneva we
trained it against we trained against
hundreds actually our sensors around the
world
and then then took the results of that
and were able to scan the whole internet
uh we scanned the end of it almost 50
times actually ipv4 internet with these
different with these different packet
sequences that geneva discovered and
effectively just attacked ourselves over
and over and over again yeah to see what
kind of uh damage we could do
and how does that square so before you
said we're never going to release
anything that helps the sensor in any
way and now you're releasing a recipe
for launching massive attacks on
something right how does i mean i i i
usually think you know any technology
can be used for like with that i could
actually attack the sensor directly
right and and just make their life
miserable um using their own
infrastructure which is ironic even uh
right um i could use it to you know i
could use it to ddos uh the red cross as
well uh so that my perspective usually
is that any technology can be used for
good and for bad uh but you've before
said a little bit into the direction we
never want to publish anything that
helps the sensor uh this seems to be
different what what's different here
yes the difference the difference here
is and i want to note that we didn't
just discover these and just immediately
put them out into the world so we spent
almost a year actually just doing
responsible disclosure
we emailed every middle box manufacturer
we could we could get in touch with and
gave them advanced copies of our paper
advanced copies of this attack
we actually emailed there's something
called certs country level emergency
readiness teams
these are teams that exist in various
parts of the world that are basically
designated to respond to network events
pertaining to that region so we emailed
all of them around the world like hey
that chinese sensor you guys are
operating
potential problem there
so we spent months and months working
with ddos manufacturers certs
middle box manufacturers to try and
patch these things and clean them up
before this ever got out into the world
at the end of the day this kind of runs
into this this broader responsible
disclosure
uh thing that a lot of the security
field wrestles with of if i never
publish this there's often no incentive
for for this issue to be patched yeah
like if there's no there's no downside
to the network they don't need to patch
it and if someone else discovers it
before this gets out there then they can
start using it without it being without
the world and the defenders knowing
about it yeah
so there's this really tricky
line you gotta tow almost of i need to
let everyone have as much time as
possible to patch it but i also need to
know it's going to get out there to
incentivize them to patch it
um so with that with that in mind we
took the approach of let's take as long
as much time as we possibly can let's
tell everyone ever any invested party
about this attack how to patch it how to
fix it we gave them scripts to test
their own network
and then after several months had passed
and we were confident that they were if
they were going to take action they
already did then we released the work
yeah cool yeah
now you're
a member of something that's called
breaker space i've already mentioned it
at the beginning do you want to maybe
because it's pretty unique do you want
to talk a little bit about what this is
and what it does
yeah i'd be happy to so breaker space is
a lab at the university of maryland uh
any umd students watching come check us
out
the breaker space lab the the kind of
defining feature of this lab is that
undergraduate students are invited to
join and participate in the lab
so it's it's the goal of this lab is to
broaden and make research more
accessible beyond just like pc students
and graduate students who are doing it
so this geneva team and the broader
censorship team within this lab has been
staffed i've been leading the team but
i've had a team of undergraduates who've
been working with me on these projects
so every every project we've talked
about today and every paper on our our
website it's this has not just been a
one-man show this has really taken a
village to get these off the ground and
get these moving they're it's huge huge
tasks and um i'd be remiss if i didn't
mention the huge team of students who've
been working on this with me
and okay not
unrelated to them being undergrads or
not did you like how often does it
happen that you get into like hot waters
like you know they're you know in
security research there are
national defense implications there are
legal implications and so on like how do
you navigate that space and how often
does it happen that you're like oops i i
hope no no one noticed this
it definitely it definitely happens um
and it's we're really lucky to have such
a supportive like university atmosphere
in which we can do these things yeah uh
we've worked closely with um irb the
institution review board and our network
security people um i mean there was
there was one week where we for that
scanning people were talking about we're
like all right let's kick off some scans
and then we immediately knocked out the
university firewall it's like oh no
um and they worked with us and helped to
get it back and then helped work in such
a way that wouldn't happen again so what
you're describing absolutely happens um
i mean one time we were accidentally we
didn't know this we were accidentally
attacking like the city of jacksonville
florida and it was like
whoops let's let's go email them so that
stops happening like the university of
kentucky things like this so what you're
describing happens all the time it's
like oh shoot whoops and often those
like whoops moments are like that's a
cool discovery you just made uh we also
got to go fix whatever you just broke
yeah
so totally happens happens all the time
we got lots of crazy stories like that
um we're really lucky to have such a
supportive atmosphere in which we can do
these things it's okay to break things
um as a work to fix them obviously in
such a supportive atmosphere yeah
where can people go if they want to get
started in this space like let's say i'm
an ai researcher i want to i have a good
understanding of whatever
reinforcement learning and and
evolutionary
methods and genetic algorithms and all
like but i've not much clue of security
is there resources i can i can go to
that you can recommend
so for security in general there's
there's so many i mean and there's i'm
sure there's a two dozen youtube
channels that could probably hook you up
with like incredible um so maybe i like
we can send someone and link some of
those below or something um i wish i
could say that there is like this
amazing
uh ai
censorship i want to say like censorship
resource space where everyone can come
to and learn how to apply ai to these
techniques uh someone like that doesn't
quite exist but there are great there
are great resources for learning about
what censorship is happening in the
world um so something like uni uh uni is
ooni it's the open
observatory of network interference
spin out from the tour team that
monitor censorship all over the world um
you could pull up the website later but
the um
they can identify censorship in
basically every country it's run by
volunteers and it's an incredible
organization so there's all sorts of
groups like this that are studying
censorship monitoring for censorship so
for people who want to break into this
more specific field of censorship
there's all sorts of great resources
sensor planet is another group run by
the university of michigan they're an
awesome team they also publish all their
data cool so all these groups have this
very open sharing like hop on their
website and they got lots of great
resources reports data you can get your
hands in
excellent uh is there is there anything
else you want to get the word out to to
machine learning and ai people uh big
open questions anything
uh that you feel should be out there
uh really just this whole space like
this this whole idea of um there's this
entire space of you can apply these
techniques to in a way that's
immediately impactful helping real
humans on the other side and humans who
kind of need this help like you have
this potential to make a real immediate
impact on the world
so it's a great space to get involved in
excellent kevin thank you so much for
being here and bringing this a bit a bit
closer i i know more i hope everyone
else does too now uh yeah thanks so much
for having me this has been a blast
excellent super appreciate it bye
[Music]
you